هذه هي صور التي عرضها التلفزيون الايراني
لاخر ما تبقى من اثار الواقعه مسيره صغيره
محطمه ومحترقه واضرار جزئيه في سقف المبنى
العسكري المستهدف حدث كل شيء في ظرف زمني
وجيز حسب روايه وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
فانه هجوما غامضا استهدف مصنعا عسكريا في
محافظه اصفهان وسط البلاد تبين لاحقا انه
نفذ بثلاث طائرات مسيره صغيره تعززت
الروايه الايرانيه بتفاصيل نشرتها وكاله
الانباء الرسميه ذكرت ان هذه المسيرات من
طراز كواد كوبتر كانت محمله بقنابله صغيره
اطلقت اثناء الهجوم وكوت كوبتر هي مسيره
تطير لمسافات قصيره نسبيه وقادره على حمل
قنابل صغيره تقول وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
ان دفاعاتها الجويه اسقطت واحده منها بين
من فجرت المسيرتان الاخريان لجنه الامن
القومي والسياسه الخارجيه بالبرلمان
الايراني
كانت بدات تحقيقا بشان الحادثه وعلى اساس
نتائجه ستتخذوا القرارات المناسبه رجح
نائب محافظه اصفهان في البرلمان الايراني
وقوف اسرائيل وراء الهجوم لكنه السدره
بالقول انه يجب انتظار نتائج التحقيق
سريعا دخلت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بنفي
قاطع لاي مشاركه من قوه عسكريه تابعه لها
في الهجوم وذاك بعد ما كشفه مسؤولون
امريكيون لصحيفه جورنال بان اسرائيل هي من
نفذت الهجوم يقول الايرانيون ان الهجوم
كان فاشلا فكل ما اسفر عنه اضرار جانبيه
على سقف المصنع العسكري ولم تتاثر للمعدات
بداخله بينما نقل مراسل اكس عن مصدر وصفه
بالمطلع قوله ان القصف كان محددا وان
اربعه مواقع مختلفه للسهدفه بدقه